Quand Chris m'a proposé de venir parler, j'ai dit non.
Je ne me sentais pas capable d'établir le lien entre moi et le public,
c'est trop grand.
Mais il était dans la panade, et n'arrivait pas à trouver le genre de sex-appeal
et de classe qui a fait la renommé de cette conférence (Rires)
J'ai fini par dire « Ok, Ted, je veux dire Chris. À deux conditions :
primo, je veux parler le plus tôt possible dans la journée.
Et secundo, je veux choisir le thème pour TED 2006. »
Et il a heureusement accepté. Et le thème sera, dans deux ans
« Chatôns mignons en photos ».
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'ai inventé l'appareil photo placebo.
(Rires)
Il ne fait pas de photos, il ne coûte presque rien, et vous pouvez toujours dire : j'y étais.
« Chez Monsieur, meilleurs vœux à vous et votre famille.
Je sais que cette lettre pourra vous surprendre,
mais veuillez considérer que le destin qui frappe à votre porte n'est jamais annoncé.
Les honnêtes gens sont rares mais prévalent, dit-on.
J'ai décidé de vous contacter moi-même pour m'assurer de votre honnêteté,
au cas où je vous confierais une partie de mes fonds personnels.
Je m'appelle Michael Bangoora, fils de feu Tiamu Bangoora
(Rires)
ministre de l'Économie en Sierra-Leone
(Applaudissements)
avant d'être assassiné dans la guerre civile.
(Rires)
Sachant votre pays propice à l'investissement économique,
et que vous êtes aussi transparent que digne de confiance,
j'ai décidé de votre écrire.
(Rires)
Avant que mon père ne décède, il possédait 23 millions de dollars américains,
qu'il protégeait des leaders rebelles au plus fort de la guerre.
(Rires)
Ces fonds devaient être utilisés
pour réhabiliter les réservoirs d'eau à travers tout le pays,
avant le début de la guerre. Quand la guerre éclata,
les leaders rebelles exigèrent les fonds.
Mon père prétendi qu'ils n'étaient pas en sa possession,
et il fut tué pour avoir refusé de les lâcher.
Seuls ma mère et moi sommes au courant pour les fonds,
mon père se confiait toujours à moi.
Je m'arrangeais avec quelqu'un de la Croix-Rouge qui passa l'argent à l'aéroport,
sans jamais savoir le vrai contenu de la boîte.
(Rires)
Pour rassurer ma famille, les fonds furent déposés
dans un coffre d'une banque fiable de Dakar, où j'obtins un asile temporaire.
Je ne souhaite pas investir cet argent au Sénégal,
car le climat économique n'est pas favorable, et trop lié à mon pays.
Tout ce que je vous demande, et je sais que vous feriez ça pour moi,
c'est de premièrement garder confidentiel ce transfert d'argent sur un compte fiable
deuxièmement, fournir un compte sous votre contrôle où les fonds seront déposés
et troisièmement, recevoir les fonds sur ce compte,
prélever votre commission, et conserver le reste
jusqu'à mon arrivé, après que le transfert soit achevé.
Mes amitiés sincères, Michael Bangoora. » (Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je suis un peu embêté.
On m'a dit en coulisse que j'avais 18 minutes.
Je n'en ai préparé que quinze. (Rires)
Donc si ça ne vous dérange pas, je vais en laisser passer trois.
(Rires)
Je suis vraiment désolé.
(Applaudissements)
Comment vous vous appelez ?
(Rires)
Mark Serfaas. Plutôt cool, non ? À la recherche du bonheur ?
Vous êtes puceau ? Puceau ? (Rires)
Au sens « TED » du terme ?
(Rires)
Donc oui ? OK. Donc, vous êtes quoi...
genre 1000, 2000. Quelque chose dans ce goût-là ?
Vous ne voyez pas de quoi je parle ?
(Rires)
Mark
Serfaas.
(Rires)
1860, n'est-ce pas ?
Et il n'y a aucune raison d'en avoir honte.
(Applaudissements)
Hier soir, je suis sorti avec des gars de chez Google.
Vraiment cool, on était complètement défoncés. (Rires)
Et ils me disaient que leur moteur de recherche était si avancé
que, d'après mes interactions avec Google au cours de ma vie,
ils pouvaient prédire la prochaine phrase que j'allais dire.
(Rires)
Moi j'ai dit, « Mais dégage, c'est n'importe quoi. »
Mais ils ont dit « Non ! Mais ne le montre à personne ! »
Et ils m'ont dit qu'il suffisait de taper « Quel est-ce je m'apprête à dire ? »
et mon nom, et Google me le dirait. Et je dois vous préciser, je n'ai rien modifié,
c'est un vrai navigateur Internet et le vrai Google,
et nous allons le tester en live aujourd'hui.
« Qu'est que je m'apprête à dire ? » Et « Ze Frank », c'est mon nom.
Ais-je de la chance ? (Rires)
Est-ce que j'ai de la chance ?
Public : Oui !
(Rires)
Oh, c'est stupéfiant !
En mars 2001,
(Rires)
Je me suis filmé en train de danser sur « Justify My Love » de Madonna.
Et le jeudi, j'ai envoyé à 17 amis un lien vers le site où étaient ces clips,
en tant qu'invitation à mon trr... une invitation à mon trrr...
trr... vingt-sixième anniversaire.
(Rires)
À partir du lundi, plus d'un million de personnes venaient sur le site chaque jour.
Photos : Avant / Après. (Rires)
Après une semaine, EarthLink m'appelle : vu un surcoût de 10 cents par mégaoctet,
je leur devais 30 000 dollars.
(Rires)
Il va sans dire que j'ai pu quitter mon emploi.
(Diapo : être viré)
Et devenir enfin, vous savez, freelance.
(Diapo : chômeur)
Mais certains me considèrent plus comme un gourou de l'Internet (Diapo : crétin)
ou un pandit. (Diapo: perdant) (Rires)
Mais j'avais quelque chose.
J'ai mis au point une philosophie complexe,
je ne rentrerais pas ici dans les détails,
car c'est un peu trop profond pour vous autres, (Rires)
c'est à propos de ce qui rend les sites Internet populaires
(Diapo : danser bêtement et ne rien vendre)
Dommage que je n'ai pas plus de temps. Peut-être l'année prochaine, qui sait ?
(Rires)
Je suis obsédé par les emails. J'en reçois beaucoup.
Quatre ans plus tard, je reçois encore entre 200 et 300 emails par jour
de la part de gens que je ne connais pas, et ce fut l'occasion
de découvrir de nouvelles cultures.
Une sorte de microscope pointé sur le reste du monde.
Vous pouvez jeter un oeil sur la vie des autres,
et je retire aussi beaucoup d'inspiration du visiteur moyen.
Quelqu'un m'a écrit : « Hé, si tu viens à Boulder, viens t'éclater avec nous ! »
et j'ai dit « Pourquoi attendre ? »
Ils m'ont dit « Hé Ze, sympa, mais je pensais au genre de délire qu'on fait tout nu. »
(Rires)
Et j'étais bien embarrassé. Mais vous savez, c'est une sorte de collaboration
entre moi et les fans, donc j'ai dit « Bien sûr ! »
(Rires)
Je vous entends murmurer.
Vous vous dites : « Ça alors ! Comment fait-il pour avoir une présentation si bonne ? »
(Rires)
Et je dois vous avouer que ce n'est pas que moi, cette année.
Chris a sa part de responsabilité, car les années précédentes
j'imagine qu'il y a dû y avoir des speakers plutôt mauvais à TED.
(Rires)
Et donc, cette année, Chris nous a envoyé un simulateur de conférence TED.
Qui nous vraiment permis à nous, intervenants,
de nous entraîner chez nous, de façon à être prêt pour cette expérience.
Et je dois vous avouer, je suis vraiment très content d'être ici.
(Bruit : Applaudissements)
Je voudrais vous raconter une petite blague. Il n'y a pas que les trucs sympas.
Les nuisibles :
Voix : Hey, abruti, dégage de la scène.
Dégage toi-même.
(Rires)
Voix: On veut Malcolm Gladwell.
(Bruit : Bébé)
(Bruit : Ovation)
Au cas où vous manqueriez de temps :
J'avais juste une dernière chose à vous dire, je voudrais
(Rires)
vraiment vous remercier d'être venu.
Et le mode grenouille.
Ah... La première fois que j'ai fait l'amour avec une langoustine !
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Des gens m'ont dit,
ils m'ont dit : « Ze, tu fais tous ces trucs, ces trucs sur Internet,
et tu ne gagnes pas un sou.
(Rires)
Pourquoi ? » Et j'ai dit « Maman, Papa,
J'essaie ». Je ne sais pas si vous êtes au courant, mais le marché du jeu vidéo,
les gosses jouent à ces jeux vidéos, et apparemment, c'est un gros business
je veux dire, genre 100 000 dollars par an, voire plus, sont dépensés pour ces trucs.
Donc j'ai décidé de tenter ma chance.
Et j'ai créé quelques jeux.
(Rires)
Celui-là s'appelle « Athée. » Ça devrait bien marcher avec les jeunes.
Voyez, je peux me déplacer, dire des choses.
Fin du Jeu. Il n'y a pas de partie suivante. (Rires)
(Applaudissents) Il n'a pas très bien marché.
(Rires)
Je ne vois pas ce qui vous faire rire. (Rires)
J'aurais dû faire ça plus tôt, j'ai essayé de le vendre.
« Bouddhiste », bien sûr, ressemble beaucoup à « Athée ».
(Rires)
Mais vous vous réincarnez en canard.
Et c'est vraiment cool car pour quelques centimes, vous pouvez y jouer des heures.
(Rires)
Et Chris m'a dit par email
que je devais amener du nouveau à TED, du jamais vu.
Donc, j'ai créé ce jeu pour TED. Il s'appelle « Chrétien ».
C'est le 3e de la série. J'espère qu'il se vendra bien.
(Rires)
Une préférence ? Bon choix.
Vous pouvez attendre la Résurrection, qui est
(Rires)
un nombre aléatoire entre 1 et 500 millions.
De quoi on parlait déjà ? Ah oui, les merveilles de la technologie.
(Rires)
Ces merveilles pour moi ont un vrai sens, car j'en tire un vrai plaisir.
En fait, faire des choses en utilisant ces technologies
et je suis sérieux là, même si j'utilise ma voix sarcastique.
Un instant, j'arrête. Faire des choses...
Faire des choses me rend très heureux.
C'est le fait de créer qui me maintient juste au dessus de l'anxiété perpétuelle,
et c'est ce sentiment d'avoir fini un projet à 80 % : vous savez qu'il reste à faire,
mais que ce n'est pas fini, et que vous ne recommencez pas autre chose,
qui comble ma vie.
Ce que j'ai fait, c'est commencer à m'intéresser
à la création d'espaces sociaux en ligne pour partager ce sentiment
avec d'autres gens qui ne se considèrent pas comme des artistes.
On entre dans une culture de gourou : c'est si dur d'utiliser certains logiciels
qui sont incompréhensibles, que certains se sentent obligés de lire le manuel.
Donc, j'essaie
(Rires)
J'essaie de créer ces activités très simples
pour permettre aux gens de s'exprimer,
WhoOA, je suis sur la page, mais elle n'existe pas...
(Rires)
C'est comme… Non, sérieusement, (Rires)
J'essaie de créer des environnements sensés où les gens peuvent s'exprimer.
(Rires)
Là, j'ai fait un concours « Quand les fournitures de bureau attaquent »
qui je pense, a vraiment trouvé son écho auprès (Rires)
des employés de bureau.
(Rires)
Plus de 500 photos en trois semaines. La mode façon papier toilette.
Une fois de plus, du monde entier.
La montre est particulièrement impressionnante.
(Rires)
Des outils de dessin en ligne, il y en a beaucoup. Je les trouve formidables.
Ça permet de jouer avec des crayons
et toutes sortes de trucs. Mais c'est le processus qui m'intéresse,
le processus de création, c'est l'évènement qui me fascine.
Et le problème, c'est que la plupart des gens sont nuls en dessin.
Et ils restent coincés sur ces petits personnages avec des traits,
cette petite chose très laide qu'ils créent.
Et finalement, ils arrêtent de jouer avec, ou dessinent des zizis ou ce genre de choses.
(Rires)
Le Scribbler est une tentative d'outil génératif.
Autrement dit, c'est un outil pour vous aider à dessiner.
Vous pouvez dessiner un bonhomme, il va s'associer à votre création
pour produire une sorte d'esquisse germanique d'après-guerre.
(Rires)
En fait, il fonctionne mieux lorsqu'on dessine des trucs moches.
Donc, allons-y. Et lançons le Scribbler.
L'idée, c'est que vous pouvez participer au processus
et transformer quelque chose de laid en quelque chose de beau.
Et voilà quelques-uns de mes préférées. C'est une petite marionnette
qu'on m'a envoyée.
(Rires)
Chérie. Vraiment de belles choses.
C'est assez incroyable. C'est une fille de 11 ans qui m'a envoyé ce dessin.
C'est vraiment superbe.
(Rires)
Sérieusement, j'en suis baba ! C'est pas une blague.
Mais je pense que c'est quelque chose d'agréable et d'utile.
Et voici le Projet « Fiction ». C'est un espace en ligne,
qui est foncièrement la refonte d'un forum
pour l'écriture de fictions à plusieurs.
Ce sont des haïkus.
Aucun des haïkus n'a été écrit par la même personne, aucune ligne ;
chaque ligne est écrite par une personne différente à différents moments.
J'aime le : « A l’attache, fil à la patte
Maitresse cruelle s’approche ; fil à la patte, mis en route. »
C'est fascinant, je vous assure.
Si quand vous rentrez chez vous et que votre femme, ou qui que ce soit d'autre,
vous dit : « Faut qu'on parle », ça peut vous crisper jusqu'aux os.
Mais les activités périphériques, comme celles-ci,
permettent aux gens de se rencontrer, de faire des trucs marrants,
de faire connaissance. Ce genre d'activité facile d'accès est à mon avis la clé
pour développer les liens entre êtres humains dont nous manquons.
Rapidement : J'adore les marionnettes. En voilà une.
Elle danse sur la musique.
Lotte Reiniger, spécialiste des ombres chinoises, fît des choses plus élaborées.
J'ai commencé à m'intéresser aux marionnettes.
Juste une dernière chose : Voilà comment on fait des marionnettes.
(Applaudissements)
Chris : Mesdames et messieurs, Ze Frank.